[Music]
i wanted to do this because i felt like
the only thing that i could speak very
passionately about is empathy
you start to realize that there's more
going on in the world than you and your
dreams
this class will help you learn how to
harness the power of empathy to
transform everything that you do and
everything that you are
this is one of those subjects that just
needs many people to come in here and
talk about it from their point of view
empathy's greatest potential is equality
for all mankind
we've never seen that
we don't know what that looks like
it's never happened
[Music]
what does it mean to imagine what it's
like to get inside of the skin of other
people it's connected to a way of life
and empathy is at the center of it
empathy allows us to overcome the labels
of race and gender and caste and class
you can't have art without empathy if
you don't understand the physical and
emotional experience of other creatures
then your art's going to be dead
it feels good to achieve together even
in the most individualized sport empathy
will allow for connection
empathy is most needed when it comes to
leading
and recognizing that not all people are
you
a lot of us are very set in our ways we
think what we think we're not really
interested in outside points of view but
you don't really ever grow when you
allow yourself to be constrained like
that
curiosity and empathy are the tools that
i use when i'm working in the studio
curiosity is the vehicle that gets you
to a place of empathy
the day that you put a lid on your
curiosity is the day that you die
i'm robin habisson i'm roxanne gay i'm
walter mosley i'm robert refgen i'm
gloria steinem i am cornell west i'm
pharrell williams and this is
masterclass
[Music]
you